this episode was made possible by
generous supporters on patreon hey
crazies black holes are insane
did you know they can spin what I know
right let's compare and contrast
according to general relativity a
non-rotating black hole has two parts an
event horizon a boundary we can't see
beyond and a physical singularity a
point of infinite density and infinite
curvature a rotating black hole has two
event horizons and a ring singularity or
regularity which is a ring of infinite
density and curvature now all of this
might leave you wondering how can
anything possibly have an affinity and
weight to event horizons what does that
even mean all of which are not only
valid questions but they're good ones so
let's keep something in mind unless
something can be experimentally verified
you probably shouldn't call it science
having points or rings of infinite
density is fun math but cannot be
reality so all this really shows us is a
place where the math doesn't match our
universe not where the universe is
broken whether the black hole is
rotating or not our clear scientific
knowledge ends at the event horizon
we'll be ignoring any results the math
gives us inside it
that being said anything outside the
event horizon is fair game and there are
three things we can detect there well at
least if we ignore quantum mechanics one
mass or better yet energy to charge and
three angular momentum mass is the
easiest thing to detect about a black
hole it shows up in the curvature of
space-time near a black hole and farther
away we can sometimes see stars orbiting
it like the supermassive black hole at
the center of our galaxy charge is
detectable in a similar way it leaves an
electric field outside the event horizon
full disclosure though while charged
black holes are possible they're not
very likely it would quickly attract a
bunch of opposite charge and become
neutral the same cannot be said for
angular momentum or spin
unlike charge spin is something that
black holes definitely have how do we
know that conservation principles just
like the amount of energy and the amount
of charge stay the same over time so
does angular momentum you've seen this
before with figure skaters if they bring
their mass in closer to the axis of
rotation they speed up stars are
spinning too when their cores collapse
into black holes they speed up just like
the figure skater and a black hole is so
much smaller than the stellar core that
made it tiny by comparison they go from
the size of a star to the size of a
small city that is a dramatic change in
size which means there's a dramatic
change in rotational speed how fast are
they spinning fast let's say we're
dealing with a small one like three
times the mass of a Sun its event
horizon will be spinning at about one
tenth of a percent the speed of light
that might not sound like much but it's
around 1 million miles per hour that's
fast and those are the slow ones if
they've been around for a while they can
absorb angular momentum from the stuff
they eat and they'll speed themselves up
over time the supermassive one at the
center of our galaxy is spinning it over
30% the speed of light there is an upper
limit though they seem to max out at the
speed of light which makes sense since
that's the universal speed limit also if
they spun any faster the event horizon
would disappear exposing the physical
singularity to the rest of the universe
it would be called a naked singularity
if it could happen which it can't anyway
if you want to know more about how we
actually measure the speed veritasium
did a great video on this recently I'm
not gonna talk about it I'm not an
experimentalist hey rich sidetrack don't
forget to talk about your herbal fear oh
right right I almost forgot thanks
Newark alone the ergo Sphere is a weird
region of space just outside the event
horizon here's the outer edge of it
compared to the event horizon itself but
to really understand what happens in
there
we need the space-time metric this is
the familiar metric around a
non-rotating black hole like any metric
it's basically just Pythagorean theorem
for four-dimensional space-time if
you're subscribed and have been watching
for a while you've seen this before
subscribe
are you ready this is the metric around
a rotating black hole angular momentum
really messes everything up it's nasty
thankfully we don't need to do any crazy
math with that thing we just need to
look for some patterns this thing here
is in a denominator so when it's zero
this fraction blows up to infinity so
this tells us where the event horizon is
this term goes to zero before we get to
the event horizon where that happens is
the outer edge of the Ergo sphere if the
math is getting overwhelming just
remember this diagram from earlier the
Ergo sphere is outside the event horizon
and let me tell you so weird happens in
there as the black hole spins it drags
the surrounding space-time along with it
as well as any matter and light in that
space-time we call it frame dragging
because your entire frame of reference
can get dragged along with the black
hole's spin inside the ergo sphere your
frame is dragged so much that it's
physically impossible for you to sit
still no matter how much thrust you have
stationary paths just aren't possible
hmm this might make more sense for the
space-time diagram if we include time in
our picture a stationary path looks like
this near a non rotating black hole you
can maintain that with a good amount of
thrust but if the black hole is rotating
it doesn't matter how much thrust you
have or even what direction you point
that thrust inside the Ergo sphere
you're going to rotate with the black
hole no matter what being in there does
give you an opportunity though you're
still outside the event horizon so you
can escape with enough thrust if you go
in on just the right path and break off
part of your ship just the right way you
could escape with more energy than you
had when you entered just does that
create energy no no no don't be
ridiculous the only possibility is that
you took energy from the black hole the
black hole would slow down a little bit
losing rotational energy we already know
that nothing can escape the event
horizon so that energy must be in the
space-time outside it and I mean all of
it we can keep doing this until we've
taken all the black hole's rotational
energy in the end it'll be a
non-rotating blackhole so how do
rotating black holes work rotating black
holes have an event horizon just like
non rotating ones it's just that the
rotating event horizon is smaller and
flatter but what really makes rotating
black holes special is the ergosphere
it's a weird place where your entire
frame of reference is dragged along with
the rotation of the black hole and since
that rotational energy is outside the
event horizon we can steal it from the
black hole after all the stars in the
universe stop burning and all the white
dwarves cool into black dwarves rotating
black holes will probably be the only
source of energy left in the universe so
do you think humans will live long
enough to become a black hole
civilization please share your thoughts
in the comments thanks for liking and
sharing this video and a special thanks
goes out to patreon patrons like LT
Marshall folds who help make this show
possible don't forget to subscribe if
you'd like to keep up with us and until
next time remember it's okay to be a
little crazy the featured comment comes
from a rock shop who asked if energy
comes from the field why does the
battery matter because the electric
current is the reason the energy
transfer is happening and you don't get
a current without the electric field
from the battery there's no free lunch
all debts must be repaid anyway thanks
for watching